Aflatoxin has been implicated in
stunting of childrens' growth,
in increasing the
incident of liver cancer,
and increasing
the susceptibility
to other secondary infections,
like HIV and malaria.
So aflatoxin contamination
is prevalent in global crops.
In this project, we expressed
a small RNA molecule
in corn kernels that
could successfully
transfer into a
contaminating fungal cell
and shut off the production
of the toxic compound.
We would love to see
this aflatoxin free crop
in the hands of farmers where it
would really make a difference,
in areas in developing countries
where food security is already
a big challenge.
I remember the distinct moment
when I was in high school
genetics class where
we learned about Mendel
and the segregation
of genes, and I
felt as if I was hit over
the head with a frying pan.
I knew, at that moment,
I had to be a geneticist
and that I wanted to use
it to make an impact.